hey leute willkommen zu einer neuen
texture pack vorstellung bzw texture
pack review dieses texture pack habe ich
schon vor ein bis zwei bis drei wochen
ungefähr glaube ich benutzt
allerdings bin ich nie dazu gekommen ist
vorzustellen und zwar ist es das
shopdesign texture pack für die neueste
version auch schon draußen
das ist eigentlich dass die volltexte
pack auch in 16 pixeln paar blöcke
wurden übernommen wie zb das wasser oder
die lava auch allerdings wurden dinge
wie zum beispiel die erz und so alles
vieles musiker gemacht und auch die
wolle
das ist erstmal das ein grober überblick
gewesen wir stellen hier mal wieder
direkt durch die die neue welt die ich
hier benutzer kam er weil ich eigentlich
ganz gut an das letzte texture pack er
nicht so habe ich an den bewertungen
gesehen ganz schön mit den daumen runter
dass man sieht auf euch das gefällt und
ob es euch das nicht gefällt
und naja also hier sehen wir halt das
dingens regionen das pils die um das
sich fast gar nichts verändert vom die
volltexte pack außer die teile sind mit
simpler gewonnen können wir auch sofort
in pakistan reingucken das ist halt
alles ein bisschen grauer geworden
allgemeinen die items sind ganz simpel
eingeteilt ist einfach nur grob gepixelt
nicht in die mit schatten oder irgend
sowas sondern einfach wirklich nur
sondern apfel ist einfach nur rote damit
sage ich mal hier ein ganz normales bio
da finde ich vor allem das gras finde
ich ganz witzig also das sieht ein
bisschen von den konturen hier ein
bisschen saft raus und was sich übrigens
auch machen werde es einfach dass ich
durch diese reihen durchgehen werde
das heißt ihr werdet dann am ende sehen
wie ich dann einfach durch matsch oder
ihr könntet in die kommentare schreiben
ob ich das wirklich alles sehen wollt
oder nicht
jan welt die ganzen kühe schafe
schweine manager kay moment weiter also
die meisten davon wurden denke ich nicht
sehr bzw
gar nicht verändert also hier die wurde
ein bisschen verändert als der dinge ist
die kirche wurden gar nicht verändert
hirsch war die teile auch nicht die teil
der erst recht nicht also 100 denken wir
mal weiter zu den mops ich glaube da
wurde allgemein sehr wenig verändert die
ihr dingens wurden verändert kriegt die
wurden allgemein ein wenig da die farben
wurden als ihm klar gemacht gesehen dass
ich alles ein bisschen heller aus ihr
wurde nicht verändert
es hat mir einfach viel zu laut mal
hintenrum und gar nix saßen der spinne
um in den krieg als auch simpler
geworden also ganz einfach an
chronischen mund und alles schon
und hier haben wir kripo mann hatte ich
lasse mir einfach ein creepers bonn oder
ihr kriegt also trieb das sind echt
extrem sind wir einfach nur grün mit
seinem komischen gesichtern mit dem kita
gesicht weht da schon was ich da meine
so der community hoch
so haben wir halt ein paar häuser ich
finde häuser kann man damit jetzt nicht
so gut bauen aber ich finde damit kann
man ganz gut ein paar sachen zeigen und
das ist halt ein bisschen cooler als
dass die volltexte pack wenn man jetzt
zb in not what vorstellen will oder so
ja ja ja wir so ein paar bilder die
meisten wurden wirklich übernommen
ich glaube kainz wurde wirklich neu
gemacht und jetzt kommt wieder zu der
sache soll ich demnächst einfach dann
durch diese reihen durchgehen und
vielleicht ein bisschen musik
hinterlegen das heißt ich gehe dann hier
so durch oder soll ich das einfach
komplett lassen also das bitte dann
einfach in die kommentare schreiben
und dann würde ich sagen das war es
jetzt erstmal so grob vor dem video
wenn es euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
über einen daumen hoch freuen wenn nicht
dann bitte einen daumen runter geben und
ihr könnt mir wieder texte weg in die
kommentare schreiben
und ja jetzt würde ich dann einfach hier
südlich reihen laufen und dann einfach
schreiben ob er das gut findet oder
schlecht okay dann tschüss